we talked about Bellagio camera and
that's a well-known consumer plenoptic
or light-filled camera I'm actually
somebody wanted one of these how much
are these Oh off eBay I think than if I
should say offer you base you can say
that yeah I saw them 400 pounds on eBay
I've also attempted actually because I'm
not allowed to take this on home so
these aren't the only other cameras
though are they so is another company
called matrix who are pretty prominent
in light field they're more focused on
industrial cameras what sort of uses
would an industry have for this sort of
thing to answer that question I should
probably tell you a little bit about how
the waitress from this so first of all
what latex camera is much higher
resolution it's much more expensive but
it's much higher resolution okay you can
you can obtain 11 megapixel images with
always other my information okay but
also the approach of waitress is
slightly more pragmatic so they don't
necessarily model all the ways going
into the camera and worry about the
mathematics of how you would reconstruct
focus and things like this what they're
really interested in doing is very
quickly obtaining a depth map of the
scene so people familiar with Microsoft
Kinect will know but depth sensors are
quite big at the moment so instead of
just taking a normal picture you take a
picture and you also get a value for
every pixel of how far away it is now
the problem of Kinect is it runs on IR
so it can't be used outside and it's
very low resolution what's infrared
right infrared so yeah I mean it's very
good for skeletal tracking and gameplay
but if you want to use it to reconstruct
a vice plant if that's not what's
designed for you can give it a go but
it's not what it's time for
so the varix is a hardware based
approach that tries to reconstruct depth
and high resolution images really really
quickly so this larger can we'll take a
picture my computer will chug away for a
minute or two and I'll have a really
nice picture at the end the Ray tricks
using a GPU machine will do this in
fractions of a second okay because it's
designed that way so razor comes a
subtly different but pretty similar they
still have a main lens and a CCD and
they still have Micro lenses in front
okay ray tricks have a hexagonal micro
lens array so there's slightly less
wasted space but it's minor okay Ray's
come in on a on a matrix but instead of
being focused onto each micro lens they
focus behind
okay so babies come in like this and hit
a bunch of micro lenses and then some of
these might
your lenses will focus into focus and
some will focus nearly in focus and they
have different focuses the three
different focuses and matrix approach
this problem very much as a each micro
lens views the scene from a different
angle what can we do with that and what
they can do is the process called stereo
correspondence or stereo matching which
is a topic for another video but
essentially what feature points can we
find in one micro lens but also in our
neighboring micro lenses to give us an
idea of what the depth of the scene is
because if you close one eye and when
you open the other where you can see
your view shift and we use that to sort
of try and go how far away things are
and that's what they're doing here and
they do it very very fast using graphics
cards so what a rate which camera will
do is produce a depth map of the scene
so how far away is everything and the
color image and it will do it at you
know multiple frames per second so you
can stream video in it or you can do
sort of quick tasks of image processing
so a few examples that they show we'll
put a link to their website in the in
the comments so that you can see the
kind of stuff they do
but they'll do things like industrial
component testing so they'll look at a
very small industrial component and
because they've got a depth map they can
make sure it's been manufactured to the
right tolerances okay this cameras will
be calibrated so they know what the
depth map is in real-world millimeters
in terms of sort of Plant Sciences where
I am you can imagine that a depth map of
a plant will give you a good idea of
what shape that plant is and that's
useful for all kinds of modeling
applications or
plant phenotyping which is the idea of
extracting traits from plants and
working out which is better than another
plant and you know maybe trying to
create more drought resistant crops or
something like that those are just a
couple examples loads more things you
could use it for if you don't wants to
buy me one you know I'll put to good use
this costs you know 100 pounds now a few
hundred dollars essentially a radio scan
will be in the tens of thousands of
euros but it's a very different problem
being solved so something for everyone
for example here's the table here's the
floor where which bits of the floor and
which bits of this table can I see you
don't really care about focusing this
doesn't have a focus knob on it or any
kind of auto focus